allora io non ho la più pallida idea di
chi sia sto tizio però sta spopolando
sul web da tipo mesi non ho mai caricato
di striscio perché mi sembrava una roba
molto trash questo questo baldi baldi
giovini che vi piacciono queste cose che
non è proprio il massimo da vedere
sembra un pietro basta sembra tutto
spiano fanno più ridere basta più la pro
capite bannata dai video basta basta
qualità della grafica 1999
ok già avviare questo gioco mi fa venire
l'influenza nel caso non avesse ancora
notato questo è un gioco che dovrebbe
essere un horror questa questo è un
horror
ok se hai scaricato questa cosa non è
tanto educativa per i tuoi bambini per i
bambini non ho bambini pro grazie quindi
non lasciare che ci giochino a meno che
non gli piacciono i giochi o robert è
stato avvertito pressioni kit continuo
ok
[Musica]
chanel warning
credo che youtube si sia spinto un po
troppo oltre negli ultimi anni però è
una mia impressione per carità allora
baldis basic ciao baldi cioè il nome
bellissimo sei molto snello start quindi
questo dovrebbe sono mia insegnante che
bel m story mode a ci sono 22 st
colleziona i sette note books quindi 7
blocchi noti ed esci dalla scuola per
vincere va bene story mode scegliamo a
questa la storia modo salve se devo fare
io allora parte il fatto che la grafica
1999 è un complimento credo certo che mi
fissa va bene cosa devo leggere regole
della scuola non correre non entrare i
facoltà non bull izzare non bere non
riuscire dalla detenzione non rompere i
muri va bene 99 permesso è questo
notebook
[Musica]
cosa devo fare quindi dovremo che si
sono tanti i notebook
allora io devo trovare quello che che
questo club ok risolvi la matematica 8
più se sente di 815 9 meno 368 fjord
mamma mia la maturità che ho fatto è
servita a qualcosa
wow esisti grazie a quindi quando trovo
in ottimo che devo rispondere alle
domande che sta parlare lui
ok ho trovato così sta roba
ma io posso usare gli oggetti che trovi
in giro ok va bene qui ho trovato una
moneta va bene mi fai andare da qualche
altra parte c'è un altro blocco note
però non farmi delle domande di
matematica che già prima è stato
difficile allora 14 1
ecco ragazzi questa è la terza liceo
porca vacca
io mi incavolo ogni volta che un
problema lo sbagli e lo so anche la mia
prof era così intanto ve l'ha preso
notebook
l'importante è quello mi spiace baldi
che non l'ho saputo rispondere però
erano gli stessi quesiti che gli
ponevano al liceo non gli ho mai capito
io stesso
co demonio morto il colosso il serio che
cazzo addosso per un gioco del genere ma
no è finito ma no ma come ho perso e non
la capisco la matematica sono cose che
non riesco a capire comunque ragazzi che
se non state ancora liceo quella un
quesito da liceo adesso capite perché ho
avuto sempre problemi a scuola
3 meno 8 ma come meno 54 meno 6 meno 25
grazie allora riprendiamo tutto quindi
fatemi capire baldi è un professore di
matematica 6 13
cosa voglio scrivere quasi baldi non la
so io questa non la capisco baldi
ascoltami
capiamoci io non ho fatto ho provato ci
ho provato ti prego ti giuro che ho
studiato non le capisco le cose che se
su di sé come faccio a rispondere alla
domanda è possibile cioè dovrei chiamare
il mio prof
facciamogli saprò la porta che scappo
fortissimo
la chiusa lui cosa devo fare qua cosa
dovrei fare
allora senti e ho provato a rispondere
posso entrare velocemente nella tua
stanza non entrò nell'altra stanza o
scherzando marian ariel e allora
facciamo così non entriamo più in quella
sana non sono capace risolvere così
troviamo in un altro stato
allora ragazzi facciamo che prendo la
moneta e me ne vado via perché non non
capisco cosa devo fare lì non posso
andare via va bene non andiamo via posso
uscire non posso uscire non posso andare
da nessuna parte
mi fai uscire per favore come si risolve
questa parte qui matematica uguale a più
matematica uguale a matematica al
quadrive quando la matematica uccide
allora i ci prova l'ultima volta ma non
so cosa dare di risposta ve lo giuro
ci provo ho dovuto pensare se tra i
ragazzi non so se avete notato da un
capello che gli esce solo uno se io non
mettersi la risposta va sotto cioè come
va a finire
ma dai ragazzi dopo attentissimi calcoli
credo che la risposta giusta sia 0 punto
784 era 785 ho sbagliato io
peccato perché credo fosse proprio
questa la risposta strano che io abbia
sbagliato però vabbè comunque ragazzi e
se riuscissi a schivare il tizio visto
che si e incavolato naja ladra e la
madonna che ansia o alcol e monio se
questo passa in mezzo ai banchi o aiuto
che la facciata non mi piace così aperta
gesù esiste è veramente brutta la
faccenda amore vi segue per sempre e
devo devo devo recuperare energia solo
che quello mi segue tantissimo come
faccio devo prendere e ci sono delle
forbici le ho prese ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato
scherzavo fa piacere abbiamo fatto
uscire ho fatto serve a può aprire le
porte anche per marco demonio a ogni
volta che sbaglio si cala di più ma sto
male che brutto gioco lavora canzian
vabbè ma è bruttissimo st rocchi è
quello è passato un tizio non si può
correre nei corridoi c'era scritto prima
cosa ho visto e fallo lo scatto è che ti
costa
[Musica]
macché jump the rock veloce male ma cosa
che dia che gioco sa cosa vuol dire che
c'è uno che mi fa saltare per la corda
va bene comunque ho capito non c'era
risposto alla terza romagna dividere a
cagate poi ti segue
va dai ragazzi per quanto sia un ansia
comunque è carino cioè fatto molto bene
se il tizio riuscisse a entrare nella
porta mai a le tre caravelle che brutta
situa porco demonio schifoso via via via
con me mena mena è bruttissimo no vabbè
ma questo gioco un'ansia ve lo giuro io
sono stanco già adesso no no no non era
ora
[Musica]
porco demonio morto è difficilissimo c'è
gente che mi corre in faccia come faccio
a prendere sette notebook come allora
ragazzi la faccenda è molto più
complicata di quanto pensiamo
bisogna c'è un altro porter cui la roba
lì mi dà mi dà veramente fastidio ogni
volta mi in groppa
quindi se riusciamo ad evitare quel
punto non è male ora non posso più
tornare dietro perché mi riprende in
pieno quindi devo correre ancora così
speriamo che non arrivi il tizio grazie
fisco liberato come ho fatto
togliti che fastidio dei vent'anni per
liberarmi cos'è sta roba
ci sono un sacco di stanze ok lei di
senje madonna che bei quadri va bene
fatto tutto benissimo regole della
scuola le ho lette prima che c'è gente
che mi fa saltare la corda e non ho
capito il motivo
con questo cercando di recuperare un po
di stamina così con la nuova linfa tel
c'è la mensa madama che il gioco è
brutta storia
la soda la posso sparare addosso alla
gente addosso a baldi tipo perché prendo
anche la merendina non si sa mai
quello è un bullo quella è una palla zio
però lo sa bene chi lancio questo ha
funzionato lo ci credo che il culo
limite rest cos'è sta roba place nora
gere e lordo
più di chi l'ha portata a porta che via
porta ma non chiude la porta e fake exit
è tutto fake non funziona niente
pensavo funzionasse capitano incastrato
non posso stare qua devo togliere aiuto
alimentare naja ladra è difficilissimo
raga
sembra veramente orribile sto gioco però
ha un sacco di successo qualcuno me la
deve spiegare la situazione perché non
la capisco però ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto concludo qua qualità video
ludica nel 2018
voglio anche sguardi sto gioco giuro che
sarà il primo a farlo alle prossime
fiere
voglio gente vestita da baldi vi prego
quindi ragazzi spero io video vi sia
piaciuto se non saresti iscrivetevi e
non ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]